[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello everybody go ahead and let
people into our live Zoom so if you are
watching us on any of our live streams
and or even watching a replay and you
would like to drop join us live please
go to daily with Doc zoom.com that is
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12 50
p.m Pacific Time one o'clock Mountain
Time two o'clock Central Time and three
o'clock Eastern time for those of you
who are here in the United States but we
are worldwide even down in South Africa
where we are broadcasting throughout all
of our platforms some folks we are on so
many different platforms I don't even
have them memorized yet which I think is
absolutely fantastic because the
information that you're going to be
hearing today is not
geographically relevant it's worldwide
relevant folks my name is Becca dukes
and as the hostess of this program daily
with Doc I am honored to be able to
bring to you empowering information that
allows you as an individual to make and
fine-tune different things going on in
your life to
put you on a path on a journey to Better
Health Optimal Health wherever it is
that you're at as long as you're stuck
in air you can do things to help
oh my God
okay so
um for comes I don't know how long I was
muted how long was I muted for guys
30 seconds
30 seconds ah all right so folks you are
empowered you are an empowered
individual and those fine little tweaks
in tune tuning that you're going to hear
on today's program that are not hard
they're not hard at all we'll lead you
on a path to Better Health to find
better or even Optimal Wellness when it
comes to your health or your family's
health or your community self we're
working on the world so share this
program with others you can find us on
YouTube and Facebook and patreon and
Spotify and
um
oh but there's so many I've got to
memorize them I promise I will I will
but again my name is Becca dukes and
if you are here with us I do have to let
you know it is a FDA requirement that I
let you know that this program is for
educational purposes only on the
importance of nutritional
supplementation
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician and
we do recommend that you work with your
doctors when starting a quality
supplementation program because folks
it is proven science that we are
continually making cells so when you're
continually making something and the
stuff going into making it
is better
and improving cells and cell function
then what do you think has to do with
the chemicals that are controlling or
managing a poor health situation
they're going to be absorbed more so we
really encourage that you work with your
primary care physician because as your
body is gaining wellness and better
becoming better neutrified it will need
less of that chemical that is being used
to manage and we're not all about
managing folks we're all about giving
the body what it needs to do what it was
designed to do and that's not just
barely survive that is Thrive so if you
were invited by somebody specific to
watch this program make sure that you
get back with them tell them thank you
we are a resource to an amazing
community of coaches health coaches
certified holistic health coaches many
of them graduates of The Institute of
holistic health through their certified
holistic health coach course
you can find more information about that
course at coachwithdoc that's doc poach
with doc.com now
if you are new and have never spoken to
anybody about Dr Wallach any of the
products that have he represents or the
company that he founded
we invite you to get a hold of one of my
my team
you can go to daily with doc.com that's
daily with doc.com and there is a
contact us function there you can also
call our 800 number
855-949-3377 again
855-949-3377 now we are we are health
coaches we are not medically trained we
have not gone through eight years of
college plus residency all that stuff we
are trained on the importance of
nutrition so if you've got a
pharmaceutical question you need to get
with your doctor you need to get with
your pharmacist and ask those questions
when it comes to nutrition and based on
what Dr Wallach would recommend for you
based on the symptoms and the the
disintegration that's going on within
the body you're in the right place
so without further Ado I would like to
bring on with me the one the only
Dr Joel Wallach so Dr Wallach he has a
Bachelor of Science in agriculture so he
studied plants and soils and everything
going on there he became a doctor of
veterinary medicine where he has through
that study to become a doctor of
veterinary medicine he found in the
cause of a mass die-off of pollution
that affects the thyroid and folks if
you're having thyroid issues and you're
eating processed Meats yeah he has
already figured that out so listen up I
know it's it's like
an epidemic right now Dr Wallach with
thyroid issues hypo hyper
it's just crazy
and then
he if that wasn't enough he also found
the first non-human case of cystic
fibrosis which was said to be a human
genetic condition folks he found the
cause of it in a monkey
and he was also able to reverse the
condition
in a whole colony of monkeys
and um yeah that's not what they wanted
to hear so they fired him and he went
back to school to become
a naturopathic physician where he is
using all of his education including
over thirty thousand autopsies
through his post-doctorate and pathology
three of them to help us as humans and
our fur babies feather bed babies are
gill babies okay so Dr Wallach welcome
to a daily with Doc what great
information do you have to share with us
today
well
you said a great story there you shared
a great story and of course
um the
um
results for the NIH Grant 21 million
dollars I was at the Washington
University in St Louis I did 20 000
autopsies there
and um the text my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute is a National
Treasure because I showed I proved there
were no gently transmitted diseases okay
all the diseases said to be transmitted
genetically or autoimmune body detecting
himself no we're all just simple
nutritional official disease
and so I was very very proud of them
and
um we had to sue the FDA in federal
court eight times my great attorney
general and I to be able to put these
nutrients into baby formulas enfamiliar
Similac and the like and we were able to
get rid of scissorhibrosis we're able to
get rid of mustard the sweet they fired
Jerry Lewis these Cystic Fibrosis
Foundation fire Jerry Lewis similarly
put a gag on him so he couldn't tell
people he had found the Cure the next
day they shut down his Telethon this and
even though he had raised 2.6 billion
dollars for them or 46 years in the
Telethon uh this was September 4th 2011
they fired him in 2000
um I would see here too September 5th
2011 they shut down a Telethon terrible
terrible story
and then of course
um the whole idea
um that um these diseases are genetic is
out the window now
today
I want to talk about
the
um let's see here let's talk about
something really big let's talk about
the metabolic syndrome
okay metabolic syndrome makes up 25
percent of the American population uh
extreme abdominal obesity
type 2 diabetes high blood pressure
um
these kinds of things
and um it's one of those things where it
costs a great deal of money uh it costs
per person okay we just
um obesity okay just the Obesity is part
of it cost forty thousand eight hundred
and seventy three dollars per per year
per person okay
and um 25 of the people in the United
States are obese and then you throw them
into the metabolic syndrome
okay and then of course you also have
Highway pressure in the metabolic
syndrome
okay and we spent 131 billion dollars a
year just treating the highway pressure
and then you also have type 2 diabetes
with a metabolic syndrome okay we're
looking at 342 billion dollars a year
just to treat the diabetes part
and it's very very scary stuff
okay
how much we're spending for simple
nutritional deficiency diseases I mean
we're America nobody should be
nutritionally deficient you have access
to all these wonderful products
that actually prevent it and reverse it
nobody should be suffering nobody should
be suffering from metabolic syndrome
nobody should be suffering from diabetes
nobody should be suffering from having
pressure nobody should be suffering from
obesity these are all simple nutritional
deficiency diseases
so we have you know we have a program
for this approach to thyroid issues that
was my first
um scientific study I did I was involved
with a mass die off 500
um Lambs died in one night they were
perfectly normal one day the next
morning they were all dead and the
farmer bought me 50
of these dead lambs and they all had
goiter they all had their blood was
black not dark red but black and I asked
the farmer I said gosh what about the
rest of the lamps you saw They're All
Dead all 500 were dead this morning oh
my gosh we did they show any sickness
the day before no they were perfectly
normal the day before okay
um do you live is your farm around other
Farms oh yeah I'm surrounded by Farms
okay what kind of animals none it's all
just raising grain and oh what kind of
fertilizer they use well they always use
nitrate fertilizers I need
a couple of five gallon buckets full of
the water from the the
um Pond that they're drinking from so he
calls his people and then within two
hours I had that we did the testing sure
enough
there was enough
um nitrates in that drinking water to
kill herd of elephants okay
and what happened was for six months
just before they were ready to go to
markets this was December
1963 December 1963 just before Christmas
um these Lambs were perfectly healthy
and in Mid-Missouri the temperatures run
in December in their 30s 40s 50s 40s 50s
30s 40s 50s not too unusual and that's
what was happening but the night they
all died the temperature dropped to
16 and they all die to hypothermia
because their thyroids are all dead that
was my first scientific publication
and Marlon Perkins the old Mutual Omaha
Kingdom show used that study to get the
21 million dollar Grant from NIH which
went to the Washington University in St
Louis and I was a pathologist on the
project 10 years over 20 000 autopsies
my thesis is in the Smithsonian
institute's Natural treasure I'm very
very proud of that the book form of my
thesis sells for twenty five thousand
dollars each or sometimes thirty five
thousand dollars each depending on what
country you're in
um but we do have a summary of that okay
thesis it's called epidex I'm one of the
founders co-founders of the science of
epigenetics and that is essentially a
thumbnail sketch what was in that book
we sell for 25 to 35 000 on the 20 000
autopsy showing that there are no Jacob
Transit diseases so epigenetics
um is where most people are going to buy
because you just have to pay 25 not 25
000 and spend 25 get the same
information everybody needs that book
okay that's the beginning of every
genetics the death the death of the full
science okay and of course the fall
science was of course that everything
was caused by genetics
and that is not true there are no
technical Transit diseases
so with all that said we have programs
to within weeks
I tell people give me 90 days but
usually within weeks I don't care how
long you've had your type 2 diabetes
gone I don't care how long you've been
obese and being obese is due to
um and the metabolic syndrome is due to
nutritional efficiencies now when you're
deficient in minerals particularly you
develop a behavior called Pica p i c
eica and you just eat and eat and eat
and Frank this is your 13th meal today
well I'm still hungry that's because
they're nutritionally deficient
particularly of minerals they're
deficient minerals the developers
Behavior called Pica and they eat and
they eat and they eat you get them on
one healthy
um was our
keto Shake it's a meal replacement
okay comes in chocolate and strawberry
and um one meal a day that would be the
same meal every day
and take the 90th Century one healthy
brain and heart pack for 100 pounds of
body weight to weigh 130 550 pounds you
throw in uh one healthy Brandon hard
pack get about 150 pounds you want to
start taking two halogen hard packs two
bottles of MSM should take three
breakfast sandwich at dinner time
um
doesn't hurt to throw in I don't see
here the rebounders for a shrink uh
don't forget
um the collagen peptides let's go
without the morning drinks or the
evening drink don't forget that uh keto
Shake
uh it's remember it's a meal replacer
it's not to be added to a meal
and we have the sweeties for the
diabetes three of those twice a day
don't cold turkey off your medication
but as your blood sugar begins to drop
you can still reduce it usually within a
couple of weeks you won't be a diabetic
anymore and the same thing with have a
pressure these are ultimate daily
classic tablets go ahead and take three
of those twice it has two bottles a
month and highly pressure where he spent
131 billion dollars a year
okay just to treat the symptoms don't
call turkey off the medication but as
the blood pressure begins to drop you
can slowly reduce medication based on
the numbers obesity we spend 260 billion
dollars for that alone okay
and the medical system is making
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars a year
just treating simple nutritional
deficiencies diseases so I urge you do
your part get away from the bad stuff
say maximize absorption no fried foods
no process means no oils or gluten so we
brought around oats so sugar no
carbonate or drinks even the diet drinks
got to go and carbonated water because
they neutralize stomach acid so you
cannot absorb
minerals and digest food the good lord
gave us the ability to make stomach acid
so we could absorb minerals and digest
food
don't try and neutralize or eliminate
stomach acid as part of your healthy
lifestyle and you'll have 25 to 50
healthful years your life when you get
all that in balance
um people say well you know I tried all
this all these nutrients that didn't
work well did you get off of gluten well
no I mean you know I have spaghetti for
lunch I have pancakes for breakfast and
bread for dinner and well there you go
that's because you're not absorbing the
nutrients if you're not absorbing them
they're all coming out and the only
individuals making any benefit out of
all the nutrients you're taking are the
viruses bacteria and fungus in in the
um
the
um in the body
say again
in the body or in the sewer in the sewer
okay
so they're definitely not benefiting the
body either Dr Wallach and no using the
nutrition I've tried all those other
ones and no they didn't work but using
your synergistic formulas
I was able to
lose 100 pounds
wow and I did Keto and you lose the keto
shake and yes good foods bad foods
I focused on The Good Foods Dr Wallach
and the good foods that were not high in
carbohydrates
so I left the bad foods alone
focused on those that are on the good
food side that are low in carbohydrates
and that's how I lost 100 pounds yeah in
a good good food bad food this is in the
book Dr Walsh cooking without the bad
foods that cause bad foods and um
um every every family needs to have that
there's 300 pages of safe cooking
recipes okay and recipes and also it
lists the Good Foods bad foods very
clearly
and um
septic tank is what I was looking for
okay
when they they it's kind of like the
sewer on a farm they get the benefit of
all the nutrients coming through okay
and so
um we've got to watch it we got to do
everything right and you'll get the
benefits of all these nutrients that
have so many famous people of course we
have this this um
a chart coming out here this flip chart
okay it's coming out soon or did we get
the last two bids so we know what we're
doing here I did get one and I had that
the last one asked me one more question
that I responded to so
quick okay
72 pages and it has a lot of the famous
people athletes yeah so you're not
muffled okay athletes okay we're talking
about singers
um actors and actresses we're talking
about people who were in the government
uh we're talking about pastors and
rabbis I have pictures of me with these
famous people as we've dealt with they
and their family's problems just with
just nutrition and all the medical
doctors all the top medical doctors in
the world couldn't help them and just
nutrition and solve their problems so
there you go
there you go folks you know epigenetics
Dr Wallach was talking about and he
didn't see that I was holding that up
while he was talking about it this is my
favorite book
not my second favorite book next to the
Bible this book gave me the most hope
because I was told that I had genetic
conditions that I would just have to
live with and manage the rest of my life
and I wasn't okay with that because that
management most of it I couldn't do
because of being allergic to the pain
meds that they were wanting to put me on
and now I don't need any of them
and it's all because I heard about Dr
Wallach I followed his program I took I
drank the Kool-Aid folks okay and it
doesn't taste bad and it really does
work
so Dr well like I contribute where I am
today health-wise
physically mentally
to you so I appreciate you so much and
all of the work that you have done the
books that you have written everything
that's gotten gone into making this
information available that it is my
honor and privilege to be able to bring
that to new levels through this program
daily with Doc well we can't think
enough because you could have just
gotten better and walked away
but you have spent a good portion of
your adult life and getting this
information out to other people and
helping them get the same good results
that you got and I cannot thank you
enough you're an angel of God thank you
for all the good things you do
well at least the last three plus years
Dr Wallach
no because I didn't find you until about
seven and a half
coming up on eight years ago seven and a
half years ago
so yeah amazing folks what the body can
do when you give it the right stuff as I
mentioned our products are not meant to
heal or cure anything
but the body has that innate ability to
use the right
nutrition and put it to work within to
manufacture what the body needs for
health overall whether it's healthier
blood healthier digestive system
healthier brain healthier heart
healthier kidneys I mean we're it's all
connected and there's over 600 poor
health conditions that have been linked
to
nutritional deficiencies
it's simple
I don't understand why people make it's
make it so hard Dr Wallach
well that's because they've been taught
the doctor
or second only to God
and when a doctor says don't waste your
money on vitamins and minerals Just Eat
Right you get everything you need
people say well my doctor says I can get
everything I need just from eating right
well those doctors should be put in jail
because you cannot plants do not make
minerals minerals make up two-thirds of
the 90th Century between 60 to 90
Century terminals plants do not make
minerals plants take carbon dioxide out
of there and make vitamins amino acid
fatty acids that's true but those 60
minerals comes from the soil now here's
a scary thing nutritional minerals do
not occur in a uniform blank around the
crust of the earth they turn in veins
like gold and silver
there's some places the lands along with
milk and honey where people live a long
health of life and there's other places
where they eat the same recipes they
don't get the same results why is that
well because if you're living in the
landform with milk and honey you're
getting all these minerals because the
milk is not cow's milk or goat's milk it
is glacial milk
okay when you look at the hundreds is
there average life expectancy is 120
because they have all the glaciers
grinding up the Rocks up in the
mountains the Himalayan mountains they
drink that glacial milk water they use
it in cooking they use it to fertilize
their Gardens and Peels and irrigate
their Gardens and Fields they live to be
120. they don't have a single medical
doctor
we have medical doctors in the world
just ask them and yet we our life
expectancy is only 75.
yeah and using that glacial milk for
irrigating the crops that's how you get
the nutrition in the food folks
and when you're not doing that when the
water that is being used to water
doesn't does not have the minerals
you're getting
empty food
okay well what what happened what
happened in night in uh 1882 that
changed everything we went to
electricity for thousands and thousands
of years three thousand years or more we
were getting our minerals supplements
from the wood ashes and coal ash so
we're putting into our food we're
putting into the gardens in the fields
is fertilizer and what ashes and coal
ashes are 95 minerals and two or three
percent carbon
well at three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882
[Music]
um
Thomas Edison pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric Journey plant
and that was the beginning of the end
for our health because by 1900 suddenly
now we had over 50 new diseases nobody
have seen before and doctor said oh
these are genetic because it's the
science of genetics has just been
discovered okay so oh it's a genetic
thing and that's why all these people
are coming down with these diseases and
um it's not true there are no jiggling
transmitters well we have five people in
my family the same disease well they're
all eating the same recipe or live in
the same county or whatever and there's
something they're doing the same it is
not agent disease even if you have five
kilometer family with the same disease
and and I did I mean I I had my mother
you know all having some of these same
conditions which then is how the doctors
were able to justify I have it because
of genetics
well if it's genetic
then I wouldn't have been able to
reverse anything not saying that our
products treat virus anything but folks
I posted on my YouTube on my Facebook
page Dr Wallach before and after
pictures that have been going on back
for the last 10 years just 10 years
and the changes and I've had people
reach out and say
Becca that doesn't even look like you
there's no way possible you can be aging
backwards well I am
I am I love it
absolutely love it so for all those X's
oh yeah
um Dr wellick let's go to some hands we
have some hands here with us and folks
if you are live with us and you would
like to ask Dr Wallach a question
go ahead and raise your virtual hand go
to the reactions
uh button in the zoom menu and you'll
find that raise hand option if you are
out on YouTube or Facebook Rumble true
social
um all of the different locations that
we are now streaming and you would like
to join us live go ahead and pop on over
to daily with doczoom.com Monday through
Friday from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time
so Dr walek let's go to the first and
that is up and not Miriam go ahead and
unmute yourself hello my friend and
welcome to daily with Doc Becca hey Dr
Wallach thank you for taking my call I
have two questions if there's time for
both of them for two different questions
okay the first one is I have a I know
someone who gets migraines I used to get
migraines and I no longer get migraines
but I've taken so many products could
you tell me exactly what to recommend to
her to um help her
head feel better
okay well there's many things should be
going on there okay
she needs to be getting rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat and
butter on oats no sugar no carbonate or
drinks no buckwheat uh no carbonated
diet drinks no carbonated water and then
per 100 pounds of body weight do you
have any idea how much she weighs
about my size 100 pounds okay 100 pounds
is one healthy Brandon hard pack per
month a half of those twice a day one
bottle a month of the MSM so you take
three twice a day okay and then I also
want her to have our synaptive so you
can take three of those twice a day
that'll be two barrels a month of
synaptive she also needs the I-26 or the
tubals we have the pills we have the
powder I want to have three doses of
I-26 a day and that's going to help her
rebuild the white matter in the brain
and spinal cord okay so you know does
she just have things going on there uh
because she has low blood sugar all that
kind of stuff well she does she have
diabetes or have a pressure
I don't know I don't know I was going to
recommend these things to her but
I can call with her sometime if that's
okay well go ahead no go ahead and just
give her that recipe and let's start her
there let's see how we do okay great
second one quickly
um I have been on the 90 for life for
maybe 10 years and my health has
improved so much but I was not paying
attention to my eyes and I was just
diagnosed with glaucoma so can you tell
me what I should add to my program okay
well glaucoma is where you get pressure
go up in the eye right
okay so you get rid of all the bad foods
you get on how much you weigh you said
100 pounds okay so one healthy brand
hard pepper month I have those twice a
day one bottle a month of the MSM
go ahead and take um three of those
twice a day so now I have to take three
of those twice a day those two barrels a
month the I-26 you want three servings a
day I like the chewables myself but the
pills and capsules we sell a lot of
those okay but also
the octave
I want to take three of those twice a
day they're small bottles okay so you're
gonna need two of those bottles a month
and
you could have honestly approach to the
skull squeezing the optic nerves the
optic artery the optic vein causing the
the
um
uh pressure to go up in the eye okay
and um there you go so give it a shot
and then give us a call because you're
going to have a great story great thank
you good yeah don't don't don't let them
talk into surgery okay no way okay
bye-bye thank you all right thank you so
much Miriam great questions and yes I'm
so glad that you're doing so much better
so I've been following Miriam for a
little bit and she's just
vibrant I love it Dr Wallach let's go to
the next question and I'm going to call
on David so David
go ahead and let me see if we can get
you unmuted my friend he's had his hand
his other hand up and contacted me
before
um so David go ahead and unmute please
yeah I've unmuted I'm not sure about the
background sound can you hear me yes you
hear me okay okay great hey Doc um I'll
be con I'll be talking with you next
week about the uh the egg and the
cholesterol thing I talked about on
threads that time but I'm taking here on
Rebecca today uh because
um I'm about to be taking my dog into
the rabies shot and um and the thing is
that last week
oh
uh oh yeah he's got some some connection
issues but so to finish his question Dr
Wallach he's getting ready to take his
pup in for a rabies shot and he's
wanting to know your view on that as a
veterinarian
okay well rabies shot is one of the
safest shots out there when it comes to
dogs okay
um and Brady's of course back in the
days of the Bible was a terrible
terrible disease you get a wolf or a
coyote or a dog get rabies and go
through the community and invite people
and give people rabies and stuff like
that was a terrible thing so they came
out with the vaccination was very very
good
and
um it's one of those things where it
doesn't cause any problems for the Pips
doesn't cause any problems for the
people who own the pets it's a very safe
vaccination a lot of experience with it
and so if you don't get the rabies shot
and they have a law uh in your community
that you must if you have a dog you must
have you know a rabies shot because they
don't want to have anything happening in
the community so they pass along says
all dogs must be vaccinated for rabies
then you're risking you know jail time
and
tickets you know and high-end money
thing so and rabies shots do not kill
dogs rabies shots you know kill the
owners it's a very very safe vaccine
so how do they contract rabies
um buy a bike from a rabid carnivore a
dog a coyote a wolf okay and through
saliva it's a saliva it carries the
virus the rabies virus
thank you so much for that answer Dr
Wallach next let's go on over to Phyllis
with her hand up I think she's the next
one Phyllis go ahead and you're on live
with Dr Wallach hey Dr Wallach hey you
have a contingent of loyal viewers out
in YouTube land and they have all kinds
of great questions I have several of
them
first of all Joe has a client
he is an 81 year old man
five foot eight
159 pounds
Joe says that his client has good bone
density
but the client is wondering if he might
have a possible issue with bone marrow
is that possible even if his density is
good
yes okay it's possible
um because the bone marrow can fill up
his connective tissue and the actual
bone bony bone could be normal and when
you lose your bone marrow
okay
um it gets filled up with connective
tissue and Scar Tissue you lose your
immune system because your bone marrow
is where your white blood cells your
antibodies and platelets and red blood
cells are formed so
um if he's worried about that he needs
to be taking our
um
let's see here bone Builder you can take
five of those twice a day I do that I
take five twice a day the bone Builder
um I also take uh the uh let's see here
I like our vitamin D3 even though I live
in Southern California I get out and I
do sunning two or three days a week I
spend half hour out in the sun just
purposely to get the sunlight but I
still take my vitamin D3 three of those
twice a day
also uh wouldn't hurt to make sure that
uh getting the rebound or sport shrink
as opposed to soft drinks and that kind
of stuff and juices or sports drink
rebound has a hundred nutrients
including 75 minerals which help the
bones okay
so that's where I would go
was also wondering
um
about gallbladder stones and kidney
stones and are they both caused by
osteoporosis or do they have different
causes again this would be gallbladder
stones and kidney stones okay they're
two different issues okay kidney stones
have to do
um with calcium metabolism and you're
losing calcium out of your bones because
you're not getting enough calcium in
your diet okay where does the calcium go
it comes out of your bones but then you
get some of it go to your kidneys you
get kidney stones those are calcium
the gallbladder stones gallstones have
to do with Liver Health totally
different issue okay and so this is
where you need the healthy brain and
heart pack you need the MSM
um
you need our ultimate enzymes
like all the ultimate enzymes a
gallbladder bottle because we put bile
in there and the bile will actually help
melt the
um
gallstones but you need the 90 essential
nutrients to make the liver happy so it
won't make any more gallstones okay
with the ultimate enzymes be helpful in
in getting rid of those gallbladders
okay the ultimate enzymes we call the
gallbladder in a bottle okay because we
do put the bile from the solder house
cattle we put it in there I think we're
the only company on Earth that puts bile
into our enzymes okay we call it the
gallbladder bottles our ultimate enzymes
I take three of those with each meal
I only weigh 142 pounds and I'm 84. most
people think I'm in my 50s
man oh man I am going to start doing
that I love those enzymes and finally
Aaliyah is wondering
you talk about no oils with the bad
foods we're not supposed to consume oils
what about oils from soaps Etc that we
put on our skin and our hair and she
gives the example of shea butter cocoa
butter are those oils okay to touch to
our skin and hair well if you make them
if you
make it yourself you use it immediately
fine if you buy it from the store you
don't know that it hasn't been sitting
in a barn somewhere or a warehouse 120
degrees for three Summers before they
ship it to your your sales place
okay and that heat turns those oils when
they're good when they're immediately
squished out of the food okay
but after a couple of days of the heat
it turns into trans fats hetocyclic
means they cause cancer
so you don't want those things in the
bottle because you don't know it doesn't
say
these were made in in 2022
September 2022 and we just got them now
in August of 2023
okay and so they've been in a warehouse
in the heat
in Southern California for a year no I
had no idea we need to check on the
origin of those substances that we put
on our skin and hair because they absorb
quickly
back to you Becca
all right thank you so much fellas and
let's go right over to our next hand
that is up Dr Wallach
and we have Zach Zach go ahead and
how come I can't find unmute you
if you could um there you go
Becca you have a lot of fans
congratulations on that wow we're
excited and thank you for having Dr
Wallach here all the time we uh we have
a group of more than 25 that meet five
days a week and we talk nothing about Dr
Wallach and we we mentioned you Becca a
great job you're doing thank you and the
team and the team doctor yes sir
um uh crib death
you've talked about that in the past and
the relationship with selenium and the
contribution you did to have that added
in baby formula did you just share a
little bit about that there's a client
who is very grateful you helped her with
a lot of issues
and she just wants a little explanation
of what you've done in that area okay
well
um we gotta go way back to
here you heard the story today so far
about the 500 sheep that died okay and
um
we got that big grant for 21 million
dollars for for 10 years after their
Grant was over I went to the Yorkies
primate Center in 1976 and I wasn't
there but just a couple of months I
found the first non-human case of
liberals it's a picture that's on the
front of the book epi's next with me
with that baby monkey okay it's a space
monkey okay and
um it had sir it had the
um the
the um disease okay
um
because uh cisiobrosis and I sent the
slides to five different Pathologists
five different medical schools and I
didn't tell it was from a monkey I just
said I think this is Rosary
thinking on their letter has it all came
back so yeah these are obvious cases
City roses and I told him from a monkey
we may have a uh starting a colony of
laboratory animals to study disease
they're all excited and then I got
permission to do the the biopsies and
the other 23 baby monkeys or 24 baby
monkeys a colony and they all have
physio brosis so I knew it was something
the dietitians were doing playing around
with the food and the dice and
everything because they weren't related
other than that they were monkeys they
didn't have the same mother or father
and um they summarily fired me okay when
I gave my presentation that I was going
to give to the federal government and
they fired me and that's when I went
back to school I was teaching nutrition
I said might as well get this degree
come a naturopathic doctor okay and uh
my attorney Jonathan emort and I you
know we're dealing with all these things
as crib deaths and city of roses and
muscularity and we worked with Jerry
Lewis and we worked with him Jerry Lewis
we found the contravention of cure for
must just be
um in 2000 I'll see here
um
uh we took it 2011 uh we took it uh to
the
this is September
um fourth we took it to the uh annual
meeting of the city of roses Foundation
I take it back to Massachusetts
Association they summarily fired Jerry
Lewis put a gag order on him so he
couldn't say anything about that we had
found the customer secure from us to see
the next day on the 5th of September
2011 they shut down his Telethon even
though he had raised 2.6 billion dollars
for them over 46 years but a terrible
story well so jonathanie Moore my
attorney and I will use all this
information data uh in an eight trials
against the FDA in federal court we won
and they had they forced all these baby
Farmers Enfamil Similac alike to put
these nutrients in there okay
and suddenly now all these baby diseases
went away including Senator syndrome and
doctors are saying cinnamon syndrome was
caused by the mothers laying on the
babies in suffocanium okay just simple
nutritional fishing the babies were
dying of heart attacks okay I did a big
uh interview a couple of months ago with
Charlie Ward you know big big guy from
from
um Europe uh in his Zoom goes all over
the world
and um told a story about that and of
course the city of roses went away most
risky went away and it surprised me some
of this syndrome went away okay and um
because it was just a simple deficiency
of the nutrients in the baby formulas
when we put when we forced them to put
it in the baby formulas send a death
syndrome went away
and
um it was just a simple nutritional
deficiency we have been trying to get
these nutrition nutrients put in the
baby firmness for years and the medical
doctors wouldn't let all those minerals
are toxic you can't put them in baby
formulas and so when we finally got them
in there we ended scissor roses
monstrous feet and cinnamon syndrome so
just a very simple nutritional
deficiency okay causing
um the heart attack caused by this
efficiency and this heart attack and see
we're seeing this now
um there's um
kids and they're two three four five
years old dying these heart attacks
they're not on baby formulas anymore
okay and then we're getting kids in
their teams dying of
um these heart attacks but I don't baby
Farmers anymore and when they get to be
in their teens they're going out with
their buddies they're eating badly and
eating fried foods and drinking all
these soft drinks and not taking
vitamins minerals if they do get
vitamin's Metals they'd give it to the
dog under the table they don't take them
and that kind of stuff okay and so
that's why you're seeing all these young
athletes including
um
let's see here LeBron James Ronnie James
18 years old great great kid uh very
very very good uh he'll be professional
basketball player
and he had a near fatal heart attack
okay
why would that happen he's you know only
18 years old he's fit he's you know
doing all this but he wasn't getting all
the nutrition was he eating gluten I
don't know the answer to that was he
taking all the right settlements I don't
know the answer to that but he had this
heart attack
and thank God he survived okay and we've
passed on information to LeBron James
pass to his son to get him on all the
nutrients proper nutrients sincerely the
bad stuff so we won't have another issue
like this because the second time it's
usually worse than the first time okay
and so
um this is something that people have to
understand plants do not make minerals
and minerals make up two-thirds of our
90th Century 60 of the 90 cents nuclear
minerals plants do not make minerals
if there's no minerals in the soil or
they only have the three the plants are
happy with you could be 57 sharp that's
why you have 18 different diseases
doctors oh you got bad genes because you
have all these all these genetic
diseases no you know you're just not
supplementing and you're you're eating
the same food that you're
twin brothers eating but he lives two
counties away and and he is
supplementing
and so that's why he's not getting he's
not on all the prescription drugs that
you're on okay because you're not
getting a nutrition and so these are the
sort of things that we're in control of
we get get rid of all the bad foods
getting all the 90 cents nutrients and
um
you know if they're exercising they need
to take the rebound or sports drink
which we made for sale Ratliff
uh he was a mess the Ratliff he lost his
he had a 25 million dollar contract no
excuse me 35 million dollar contract and
he lost that because he had bone
arthritis his knees 24 years old
and a basketball player
um let's see here Mike Glenn okay the
Stinger a basketball player we had
helped with his issues he brought
um
see a Ratliff to us we we came up with
the healthy Bone and Joint pack for him
which is a healthy start packing our
glucogel as our healthy bonus giant pack
we came up with a rebound or score
string for him
and he played for another 11 years and
made a hundred million dollars
now he also did a beautiful thing
with some of his money
I'm telling his money here Ratliff okay
okay he he came up with a community an
activity center okay Tia ratliff's Judd
Activity Center see a Ratliff Community
Center
and he has this for young people
and he gives them free services
what a great thing to do for your
community
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and Zach
this there is no paid advertising here
but I do want to thank you so much Zach
for for your kind words we appreciate
you and your whole entire group and
that's what this is all about folks
sharing information that allows them to
make a more educated
decision on what they can do
for themselves
Dr Wallach I have one more hand that is
up so let's go right over to Patty Patty
go ahead and unmute yourself please
hi
hi um so I have a question one of our
Associates with the youngevity wanted to
know what she can recommend her
sister-in-law or cousin or something
like that I don't have all the
information I know the little boy is six
years old he is above his weight that he
should be he has urinary incontinence
he was when he was born I'm not sure if
he when he came out he had the umbilical
cord wrapped around his neck or while he
was in the tummy but that was one of the
um
questions that or problems that he had
was the umbilical cord around his neck
and he's six years old
okay so he he's
urinating a lot right he can't hold it
yeah so he he has to wear a diaper at
six okay does he have to change diapers
in the middle of the night or
and I think it's like he has to wear a
diaper all the time because he can't
hold
it okay and you don't know how much he
weighs
no but he's um above his weight he's a
little
um okay okay so let's say six years old
let's see what uh maybe 40 40 50 pounds
Maybe
okay okay all right yeah the odds are he
has osteoporosis of the skull squeezing
the spinal cord
and that's why his spinal cord is being
told
to tell the urinary bladder to urinate
and you see this
and people of all ages when they have
osteoporosis as a skull
so because
parents and and he need to get a hold of
the book it's called it's all in your
head
and I'll show you
the it's a book and a CD set done by uh
Dr Milan and Rebecca and myself
okay when you have a normal skull up
here an autopsy it's a quarter in the
sick if as she approaches a skull at
autopsy it's
um an inch and a half to two inches
they're squeezing all the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves and also the spinal cord
and there's a chapter in this book for
each of the cranial nerves
okay in this final chord
there's 37 different there you go thank
you you get there are 37 different
diseases you can get 37 different
diseases you get okay having
osteoporosis of the skull
and again I would consider that for him
uh so it's six years old he needs to be
taking the 90 essential nutrients if he
likes if he takes pills he can take the
um one dose of the hell they ran hard
pack per month a half a dose
uh a day okay have a dose a day and then
half so you take a quarter of a dose
twice a day kind of thing okay and then
I also want them to have a rebound uh
you know in the middle of the day not at
night he'll be up all night
and also uh he needs the vitamin D3 He
needs the uh our
um let's see her seasoned salt from
Australia
he also needs to have the I'd get him on
the um uh synaptive you take two of
those a day certain amount with two day
one practice one at dinner time they
also needs the I-26 you could have one
of those tubals at breakfast lunch and
dinner so three of those chewables a day
they come in vanilla ice cream or banana
coconut they do come in capsules
um and powder I also want him to have
um are bone Builder okay
our bone Builder I want him to take
through those twice
I'm sorry MSM or no
yeah MSM is fine
okay but he still needs all this other
stuff don't don't pick one don't pick
one nutrient
okay he needs a complete program because
he's got something very serious here yes
we need to take care of his heart his
liver his thyroid his kidneys okay and
you said he did have kidney issues also
not that she knows
okay yeah it could be just a skull
squeezing a spinal cord causing all this
urination stuff
perfect thank you Dr Wallach will you
keep us informed I'm just gonna turn
around to the good very quickly and I
apologize but I got to go here gotta go
doc so thank you again so much for
joining us on daily with Doc folks
we want to thank you for taking the time
you're not just taking time you're
investing time into your own self and if
you are listing on behalf of a family
member or a friend you're also investing
this time into helping a greater cause
you didn't hear this just by chance
there is a purpose and we encourage you
to take that
time or take the time that you've spent
here and use it wisely and sharing with
others so please share this program with
with those that you know doesn't matter
what platform you're on you can just
grab that link share it copy paste in a
in a text message they make it so easy
now and we want to also ask you to save
And subscribe to our different channels
now we have something special going on
and this is for all of those that do
share the program we have what's called
DWD giveaway is that what it is to yes
dwdgiveaway.com we are doing a promotion
to help build awareness and through this
promotion I will be giving away prizes
so there's a total of 11 people that
will be one winning uh something from me
over the month of August and I think we
will depending on how well it goes we'll
continue that as well so go to
dwdgiveaways.com and AJ is getting that
all set up so that you can register for
our giveaway and then you get points
every time that you share with the
different platforms so folks we invite
you to help us get this message out so
that we can you know reach around the
world because this is not like what I
said in the beginning it's not
demographic this is a worldwide epidemic
when it comes to nutritional
deficiencies and the conditions that
have been linked to them I'm sure that
you know somebody who has something that
might have been mentioned on this
program or is affected by or their
family is affected by one of the poor
health conditions
when something has been determined to be
nutritional deficiency
it only makes sense you you work on
giving the body what it needs with that
extra support there's only one way that
the body can go and that's that's up
for the better
so
there are times where yes
it is um you know getting back to almost
too late but let's not get there folks
let's be more proactive rather than
reactive and share this message and take
action on it for ourselves and our
families if I could get my co-hosts up
with me that would be absolutely
fantastic I could not do this without
them as we have Mr giraffe they're
behind Albert joining us here from South
Africa making sure that everybody is
getting into the room smoothly we also
have Phyllis who comes to us from
uh many many years being with Dr Wallach
and sharing this program over the
Airways which I do want to do a quick
shout out
ksco k-o-m-y listeners thank you for
listening thank you for continuing to
allow us to be able to serve you with
this information so thank you to MZ and
Dave Michaels for making this program
available still on the radio and the
other radio locations let us know where
you are listening from go to one of our
uh channels and comment on one of our
shows and let us know where you are what
listening to or watching from and I also
want to thank Sherry for all she's doing
she's helping out more in not only
letting people in but also Fielding in
those those questions that are coming in
here on zoom and answering those as well
and then we have
Marilyn who is doing the dictation of
what Dr Wallach is recommending and
that's one of the biggest positive
advantages to being here live with us
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12 50
p.m Pacific time is you are able to open
up that chat and see the questions and
the responses that are being presented
on the program you can do a screenshot
of that and then take it to your health
coach and say hey Dr Wallach recommended
this for me or I know somebody that has
this condition how do I get the products
that Dr Wallach recommended and your
health coach will help you get those
products and then we have AJ
helping me with all of the technical
stuff and making sure that the stream is
going out and about and we also have
somebody that's not up on the screen
there he is we have Coach Rod who's also
helping making sure people get in and
watching out on the different channels
for questions to help fill those
questions as well folks it takes a team
it takes an army
to be able to present this information
in the way that we do and I just cannot
say enough how much I appreciate these
people they are just a small handful of
those that I have on my team that are
able to join us during this time slot if
you are not working with a coach and you
would like to you've never spoken to
anybody about youngevity or Dr Wallach
before then go to
our website www.dailywitdoc.com
and you will be able to submit your
questions and also request to have a
15-minute free consultation with one of
my coaches again this is for people that
have never ordered and are not already
talking to somebody about youngevity get
back with that person that you started
talking with they may also be one of
these amazing certified holistic health
coaches and we want to make sure that
they since they took that time to share
this information that they also have the
opportunity to continue to help you on
this health Journey
now I don't think that I forgot anything
maybe not but again go to our channels
like share comment and
dwdgiveaways.com
DWD giveaways.com wait what did I forget
AJ
oh did you put it in the chat
that's way down there
yeah there's no s song
oh DWD
giveaway.com very important DWD
giveaway.com so until next time
bye for now everyone
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]